Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and yesterday
in my Walking Dead Episode 12 review I asked
you all to submit questions.
I picked 10 to answer with one extra bonus
question.
We also owe a giant high five to the week
4 winner of my giveaway.
Congratulations to Brendan Martin.
You win a $20 amazon gift card.
I’ll be contacting you on your channel for
details.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
just as a way to say thank you to all you
guys for being awesome I’m giving away a
gift card for every episode of walking dead
this season.
Now let’s answer some questions.
Number 1 - Rachel Kang asks how come the people
in the clubhouse did not turn into zombies?
They had a class war between the rich people
and the poor people, so the ones that didn’t
turn had just been shot or stabbed in the
head.
So they wouldn’t have turned into walkers.
Question 2 - Camille Parmer asks given the
D.C spoon Beth found at the country club,
do you think that Beth, Daryl, and Maggie's
group will be the ones to make it to D.C?
Or do you think one of them will be found
by the Hunters?
I think they’ll be the ones to head to DC,
based on the teaser for the next episode it
seems like Maggie’s group will run into
trouble.
I don’t know that it’s the Hunters.
Careful for comic book spoilers for just a
sec.
But it was originally Rick’s group that
ran into them on the way to Washington DC.
They could just be changing things and giving
that plot line to the groups from this episode
or the hunters could have been that group
that Rick ran into last week.
It really does seem like Rick’s group on
the show is headed for Sanctuary, so I think
it’s safe to assume Beth and Maggie’s
groups will run into Hunters on the way to
Alexandria.
Question 3 - The Mangese asks What are the
possibilities of a Beth Carl Hookup down the
road?
Unless the groups meet up Zero, if they do
meet up before the end of the season.
I’d also say zero.
If Carl does end up hooking up with someone
eventually, it will probably be some new character
they meet in Sanctuary or another future location.
Question 4 - Trey D1515 asks Will Beth and
Daryl will make it to the Sanctuary?
I don’t think they’ll meet up with Rick’s
group, but I do think they’ll make contact
before the end of the season.
The show is really making it seem like half
of the people are headed to Sanctuary and
the other Half are headed to Alexandria.
Question 5 - z Jordan z LFC asks Do you think
Beth will die soon?
I would be so bummed, but that is a possibility.
I know that someone will die.
Right now Bob Stokey, Maggie and Beth are
highest on the list.
I agree with Beth’s comment that Daryl will
outlive them all.
Question 6 - angewomon143 asks Seeing the
new promo do you think all of Maggie's group
will make it or will we lose someone or all
of them?﻿
I think they want us to think someone is going
to die, but it seems like the worst thing
they run into next week is a group of walkers
that falls on them.
So it’s possible that someone could die
later from an infected walker bite.
Question 7 - Minitrucos360 asks in the teaser
you can see sasha scream for a millisecond
BOB, which also appears like killing something
in the floor, do you think his killing himself
or getting killed by a walker or killing someone
else?﻿
I really hope it’s Bob getting killed, because
I really like Maggie, Beth and Sasha.
But I have a sneaking suspicion one of the
women is going to die this season.
Question 8 - Josh Redgrave asks What were
you most afraid of in this ep and did it give
you any jump scares?
There wasn’t anything that made me jump,
but I did feel really claustrophobic when
they were in the trunk and I always squirm
a little when the Walkers almost bite people,
like when Beth was wrestling the one in the
country club with one hand.
Question 9 - xChaozTeamx asks What do you
think started the apocalypse?
Probably a mutated super virus.
Because the conceit is that everyone just
lives with it and they only turn after they
die I think it spread before anyone realized
what it was.
It was probably something that mutated out
of a pharmaceutical company test.
Like they were trying to make a vaccine for
something else and things just went sideways.
I don’t think it was someone evil purposefully
trying to infect the world.
I think it was all just an accident that got
way out of control before anyone realized
what was happening.
Question 10 - Infamous Adam asks I'm starting
to notice that the t.v show is catching up
with the comic, so I was wondering what would
the show do once it catch up to the comic?﻿
Robert Kirkman sits in the writer’s room
every day and writes stories with them, I
think that he has a hundred different ideas
for where the show could go if it ever goes
beyond the comic.
The spinoff show will only be stuff that’s
not in the comic, so if he can do that then
it should be pretty easy to create new original
stories for the current characters.
and one last Bonus question - TheAnanaki asks
Do you think Daryl, rather Norman Reedus,
really ate a snake in that scene?
Norman Reedus actually revealed that the snake
WAS real.
Pretty cool or pretty gross depending on how
you look at it.
So thank you so much for submitting questions,
again high five to Brendan Martin for winning
this week’s giveaway.
The next one will start with my episode 13
review.
I might also do a predictions video this week
if I have time.
I’m doing Game of Thrones and Stick of Truth
later tonight.
Game of Thrones will just post late, but I’ll
try to get Stick of Truth up in the morning.
It will just be a Let’s Play.
Right Now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for that Game Of Thrones
Video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
Remember South Park vids coming.
High Fives!